Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated actor
and comedian you know from shows
like "Community" and "The Soup."
He's the host of "Card Sharks,
which returns June 16th on ABC
and "Crime Scene Kitchen,"
which airs Wednesday night
on Fox.
Please welcome back to the sho
our friend Joel McHale,
everybody.
-Yeah!
-[ Laughs ] The entrance. Oh
-Thank you!
-Oh, no!
No, Joel!
-Yeah, yeah, yeah!
-Joel, we're trying --
-Yeah.
-Oh, man.
You've gotta --
-[ Sighs ]
-Oh, no!
[ Laughter ]
-Ohhh.
-This is --
-How you doing?
-We're trying --
Joel, we're trying not to
reward him with attention.
-What --
What are you talking about
You mean the greatest huma
on the planet? Scollins?
[ Laughter ]
-Now, Joel --
-I just --
I knew that he wore a tank top
and I'm like,
"Uhh! Now they're gonna se
my "SCOLLINS" tattoo
that I got at a Patriot game."
[ Laughter ]
-Now, I will say,
you wear a very similar
tank top to Scollins.
-Hm.
-The arm area is where
there's a giant difference
-You mean, like, the hole
in the shirt's bigger?
-No.
-For him?
-I mean from, like,
the shoulder part of the bod
to the fingertips.
-I'm not sure --
Oh, I -- Oh, I see.
-Yeah.
-I see. He's hairless.
-[ Laughter ]
-Or he's very hairy.
He's like a --
-He -- It's more like --
I would say, like,
you have giant strong arms
and he has, like, noodle arms.
-Now, how many of your staff
are showing up to meetings
in, like, tank tops
and half shirts
and, like, just mesh tops?
-I would say --
I'm doing a quick mental count
It was Scollins once
and then never again.
-Ah.
-He took -- The heat he took
I think --
He immediately went home
and threw all of his
tank tops in the garbage.
And then the garbage man
came and threw them
back into his apartment.
-Oh. You know, Seth,
I don't want to bring this up,
but I had --
I went to a burger place,
and I had half of this
kind of double cheeseburger,
and then like an hour later,
I Scollins'd all over the place.
[ Laughter ]
I mean,
I Scollins'd that toilet.
I felt so much better
after I Scollins'd.
-It happens. Sometimes
then you can just go on
with the rest of your day.
Like, you don't want a Scollins,
but otherwise --
-Yeah.
-And then I had this thing on my
finger, and I was like -- Ah
I went to the doctor,
and they Scollins'd it,
and it just oozed
all over the place.
But once they Scollins'd it,
it felt much better.
-The good news for Scollins,
I feel like he can screen-grab
just a visual of this
without any of the audio,
and it will feel like
a really good day for him.
-Yeah, it'll be called,
"Worst Biker Show Ever."
[ Laughter ]
I -- My --
The woman who did --
I had the makeup lady,
and she drew this on.
She's like, "What is -- What -
Why -- Why are you doing this?
And I was like,
"I don't really know anymore
but I'm committed to it
and I'm doing it."
And now my kids,
they're gonna love it.
This is permanent, by the way.
This is not going away.
-Good.
-Oh, and there you go.
Thank you for your
signature mug.
-Hey, you were --
-We went crazy with the Sharpi
over here, Seth!
-You mentioned -- Your kid
are 13 and 16, and you mentioned
that they'll be so happy
about this, but how --
how do kids at that age
actually engage with your work
Are they fans
of what you're doing?
Because that's a tough age
13 and 16,
as far as maybe being
a little jaded.
-Oh, I'm not
raising them, so...
Yeah. We have so -- Yeah.
The butler -- No.
Yeah. It's -- You know,
the pandemic has been great.
And it's a great way to learn.
And they -- they --
I told them
to just play video games,
'cause they might
get a job doing that.
But, no, we've watched a ton
of television, and, of course,
I'm a narcissist, so I was like,
"Watch Daddy's show!"
And so they'll watch
"Community,"
and then they'll be like,
"Hey, Dad,
that was a really good episode
except for your acting."
[ Laughter ]
And so they've turned in -
I was -- They were like,
"Dad, you totally
Scollins'd that scene."
And I was like, "Oh, that bad?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. They're -- My --
They're the --
You know how sarcastic I am.
-Yeah.
-And so they're exactly,
you know --
Like, my dad even said
when they were born,
they were like,
"You're in for it."
And there -- It's everything -
When I say to my 13-year-old
I'm like, "I love you."
He goes, "Okay."
[ Laughter ]
Great.
-I want to ask about
"Crime Scene Kitchen."
This is not a crime show.
This is a cooking show.
But a very novel approach
to cooking shows.
-Yeah.
It's where you take Legos an
you have four hours to build
and then the voice of Batman
comes out
and tells you how you're doing
It doesn't work -- I don't know.
Nothing -- It doesn't seem lik
anything really gets baked
All right.
I just promoted "LEGO Masters.
You're welcome, Will Arnett.
No, it's okay.
Everyone likes a baking show
I know you do.
-Of course.
-I can see the pandemic 20
you put on.
And, so, except this one
has, like, a mystery element
where teams go into a kitche
where something has been made,
remnants, like a little bi
of cocoa powder,
some fondant or something.
And they have to re-create
what they think it is
while somebody bleeds out
in the kitchen.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, so they have to choos
whether they provide
medical care
or if they try to win the prize?
-Uh-huh. The stakes
have never been higher.
So -- No.
So, then they have a few hours
to bake this thing,
and then we have to eat them all
to the tune of like
10,000 calories in two hours
And then whoever --
Then we reveal what it was
and then whoever is closes
moves on to the next round
And then they get --
After that, whoever wins
gets the 12:30 time slot on NBC.
-[Bleep] This is the first
I'm hearing of this.
-Well --
-And it's a Fox show!
They're letting Fox do it!
-I don't know how that --
I feel terrible.
[ Laughter ]
-You are
an emcee extraordinaire.
You do a lot of stuff
for good causes.
You did one for a zoo recently
And this is --
-Yeah.
-Your co-host.
Is this a California condor?
Is that the bird
you're there with?
-No, it's from the Andes,
which is an insult
to the California ones.
I'm pissed.
No, so, that -- Yes, that is
a real California condor.
And the condor's name is Hope,
and that means I hope
it wouldn't kill me
with its terrifyingly huge
human-sized talons.
-It's terr--
It is genuinely terrifying
I would not feel comfortable
that close to a bird like that
-Oh, they kept saying
it was going well
because when it looked at me
it didn't lunge.
So I was like, "Great!"
And it's so -- I'm not --
The look in its eyes
looked like a dinosaur.
And then it smells like vomit.
Which is also what somebod
on my chest smells like
all the time, as we know.
Scollins, what kind of
a weekend did you have?
And, so, it smells like vomi
because these things --
It's like a vulture.
It eats dead meat, you know?
It eats -- It's eating carrion
so it's very intimidating.
Again, much like Scollins,
it will eat anything it sees
I'm sorry.
I can't -- This poor guy,
I don't know what I'm goin
to do the next time --
if I'm ever allowed
back on the show.
I need another writer
to go after.
-Here is what will happen.
If he comes at you,
you will beat him to a pulp.
[ Laughter ]
So, I mean, like...
Hey, you also hosted
the iHeart Music Awards.
And this is --
-No, I didn't host it.
No, I didn't.
I just was presenting.
-You presented.
But I feel like you had a moment
there that I think,
like a gentleman of our age,
it's going to happen more often.
Where it's just a harrowin
reality of how much older
we are than who is
making culture these days.
-I couldn't agree more.
'Cause all I'm making
is Scollinses...
-Explain the photo to us.
-Oh. Yeah!
So, I was about to go present.
And that, of course, is H.E.R.
who is an Oscar winner
for "Black Messiah,"
the Best Original Song.
And, you know, I walk up,
and I look like, again,
like a grandfather,
and she's like, "Hey."
She's super nice,
and she was like,
"Hey, you're responsible
for my career."
And I was like, "Good joke
relevant musician in our time.
And she goes,
"No, no, no, when I was 10
I went on 'Maury'"...
'cause she was in a big figh
with her boyfriend and -- No
She apparently played pian
and sang beautifully,
and then Maury goes,
"So, what do you want to b
when you grow up?"
And she was like, "A dentist."
So, then --
This is when I was hosting
"The Soup" back in the 1960s
and we showed that clip
and came out to me,
and I was like,
"Hey, little girl,
stick with the singing
and, you know,
the piano playing.
You'll probably make a terribl
dentist. Just do that."
And then some music manage
saw that episode
and, you know, had a meeting
and, you know, took --
It worked.
And so I asked her
for 25% of her earnings,
and we are right now in a pretty
uncomfortable legal fight.
So, she's lovely.
So, yeah, I don't --
I'm obviously not
responsible for anything
other than continuously
going to "Maury"
for some of
America's finest clips.
-Joel, I -- This is over,
and I'm already looking forwar
to the next time you're here
It is always truly a delight for
everyone here but one person
-Who is that?
Who's that, Seth?
-Thanks for being here, buddy.
"Crime Scene Kitchen" airs
Wednesday nights on Fox.